[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
this is actually the most important
thing we'll discuss today and that's
because one of the biggest problems
today in my view is that most people in
the country
don't know how to properly cook bacon
and now everyone says they love bacon
right and this has been a an internet
meme for years where people go on and on
about how much they love bacon yet most
of the time I know you've had this
experience you go to someone's house you
stay the night you wake up the next
morning they they make breakfast they
make bacon and then and then you feel
grateful for that but then what they put
in front of you is an Abomination it's
either burnt to a crisp thereby robbing
it of all its bacony flavor or it's
undercooked and flimsy and and has the
consistency of microwave Taffy or it's
both it's kind of burnt in parts and
then undercooked in other parts and it
becomes this pockmarked a leprous
monstrosity
so I'm going to do a PSA for you guys
I want to show you an example of
perfectly cooked bacon
I'm going to show you a picture of of of
what it looks like this actually is
bacon that was cooked by one of the
great Chefs of our time speaking of
being one of the best in the world at
something
and um one of the great shots of our
time that is me
and I want to show you this picture here
it is now you see there and please leave
this photo up for a minute
first of all you see only four pieces
and
now that could remove all of my
credibility as a chef if I only made
four pieces of bacon because who does
that what sort of deranged lunatic only
makes four pieces of bacon well I will
inform you that I ate three of the
pieces before I took that picture I ate
three of the pieces
leaving four
um to split among my family and that's
four members of the family so they each
got one I got three actually after I
took the picture I had one more so I got
four and then they split the three
between them and because you know that's
what generosity is all about but anyway
what you see here is um
I want you to notice this bacon is firm
it's got the nice singe the nice
blackened Edge all around it's got the
reddish brown coloring all throughout
each slice it's very consistent the
perfect mix of of tender and crispy not
overdone not underdone the fatty parts
are also cooked not burned but cooked
melt in your mouth
a brilliant job by me an amazing job by
me now how did I do this
well I put the bacon on a preheated
Skillet heat it to medium high heat
don't want it too hot don't want it too
cool
I put it on let it sit for about three
minutes
and then I flip it give it another
couple minutes and now now that I've
done a couple minutes on each side now
I'm really just flipping it back and
forth several more times and and I'm
trying to get that perfect color and
texture it's it's more of an art than a
science cooking bacon though is all
about vigilance it's all about loyalty
heroism you can't leave the stove for
any reason eyes on the bacon at the
whole time all of your senses dialed in
sight hearing smell
become one with the bacon tap into its
essence okay you're not just you're not
just doing this visually you also you're
listening you're smelling you're feeling
you're sensing it now what my wife will
do
she'll throw bacon on the stove and then
she'll leave
because you know one of the kids fell
down the steps or something and she has
to go check
to make sure they don't have to go to
the hospital
wrong
the kid will be fine he'll figure it out
it's his fault for falling down the
steps in the first place should have
paid attention stay with the bacon
babies crying kids are screaming
doesn't matter stay focused remember
your priorities remember the great
responsibility that you assumed on
yourself when you open that package of
bacon
now you're the one who opened it and now
you're committed you have to see it all
the way through
and then here's the trick of course make
sure to take the bacon off of the stove
90 seconds before it's done so you want
to take it off and it's a little bit
underdone the grease is going to
continue to cook the bacon so you let
the grease finish the job if you take
the bacon off there's a big mistake
people make take the bacon off when it
looks perfect and you say oh I've got
perfect bacon you want to call all your
friends and family take a picture like I
did by the time everyone gets into the
room and you're taking the picture it's
ruined it's done it's burnt
why did that happen because it kept
cooking for 90 seconds afterwards so you
want to time it perfectly take it off 90
seconds before it's done
and um and then you will have
perfectly cooked bacon
this is from Chris says Matt you're
disastrous and frankly dangerously
heretical guidance on cooking the sweet
Ambrosia that is salty delicious pork
belly simply called bacon by the
untutored is nothing short of inciting
vandalism you might as well Champion
drawing crayon mustaches on the Mona
Lisa
every man with an orderly mind and
properly educated in the preparation of
the gift God literally blessed mankind
with on a tablecloth in the heavens
knows it must be grilled only a searing
well-seasoned Grill provides the proper
balance of heat and carbon required to
allow the internal fat to reach just
that crispy and tender homeostasis which
yields a perfect sweetness that can set
off any dish from omelets to oysters to
only bacon indeed the only acceptable
justification for cooking bacon in a
skillet is a need to save and use the
drippings to later Infuse into a bottle
of Kentucky bourbon your distorted views
on this topic make me question your
suitability for any future tyrannical
aspirations
well Chris
I spent 10 minutes on my show
talking about bacon
while other shows are talking about
breaking news important news like
impeachment I'm sitting here talking
about bacon
okay that's the kind of commitment you
get from me when it comes to this topic
is there any other show hosts
anyone else in conservative media
anywhere
who's going to spend 10 minutes of a
show talking about how to cook bacon
maybe there's a reason for that possible
but that's what I did and and your
response is to criticize me
your response rather than writing me an
email saying thank you so much Matt for
that beautiful presentation thank you
for calling uh calling attention to this
thank you for raising awareness about
the proper way to cook bacon thank you
for that you are a hero you deserve the
Nobel Prize you are a genius instead of
that
which is what I expect I get criticism
unbelievable
and you expect me to believe that you
know how to cook bacon
because no cooking bacon comes down to
character it comes down to what kind of
a person are you
and I firmly believe if you if you
cannot properly cook bacon that's a
reflection of your character
it's obvious that you have character
flaws one of them in gratitude
so no I don't want your ungrateful bacon
you don't need I showed you the the
photographic evidence you saw it for
yourself so maybe you need to expand
your mind a little bit I don't need a
fancy Grill I'll put it on a skillet I
could cook the bacon on a on a hot
furnace okay I could cook it if I could
cook it on the street on a 90 degree day
and it's going to look that good
it's not about the tools you use Chris
it's about the it's about the the spirit
the love
that you put into it that's what I
believe
[Applause]
Okay so
Danette has given us a picture of her
bacon her bacon dish
let's take a look at this picture that
you sent Annette
here it is now I'm going to leave that
up on the screen for a minute because we
really need to get into this
Danette you want me to review
I would give
it but you can't get offended now you
remember you asked for this
no
um
the management training course that I
took for my assistant manager job at
Domino's when I was 19. told me that you
should always couch criticism with
positive feedback as well so on a
positive note I like the idea behind
your dish I like your energy I like your
hustle I like your commitment to Pork I
like the cheddar gravy idea all that is
good very commendable
unfortunately the execution is a
disaster on the level of the Hindenburg
now this is supposed to be the finished
product correct what we're looking at
here
so you've already cooked it
if you've already cooked this
then why is there raw bacon draped over
the pork
is the pork tenderloin raw too is that
just a live Pig hanging out under there
I mean look at this bacon look at this
bacon there is precisely one piece of
bacon that is properly cooked on this
entire dish and you could spot it
yourself it's right there you see the
horizontal strips of bacon at the bottom
of the strength screen the one in the
middle right there that is the only
properly cooked piece of bacon
and how do you know that it's properly
cooked well you notice the coloring you
notice the charred edges you notice the
texture it's got all of the the
Hallmarks of a properly well cooked
piece of bacon so well done you you did
one nicely cooked piece of bacon the
problem is there's like 20 pieces of
bacon on that thing and I would never
say that it's a problem to have 20
pieces of bacon it's only a problem when
you don't cook the other 19.
now
really having that one well-cooked piece
of bacon only makes the rest of it worse
because then you get the you know now we
can compare it so compare that to the
vertical slice all the way to the far
left
um of the of the screen or no the far
right
depending on which way you're looking at
this now notice it's it's sickly pale
white appearance
it looks like it has the stomach flu
pale sweaty soggy just lying there a
limp
and you serve that to your family
are you trying to kill them my god did
not this is if my wife served that to me
we'd be in marriage counseling that's
how bad it is
now the bacon does get progressively
better as you go down the tenderloin but
even the even the best cooked piece of
bacon is not cooked
very well at all
so let me ask you this tonight when you
make meatballs do you just
you know take the ground beef and and
grab a chunk of raw ground beef and
throw it on the table
throw it in your husband's face
here's your meatball is that what you do
because that's the equivalent of what
you've done here
I can't look at this anymore I am I am
shocked and appalled I have to assume
that this is some sort of practical joke
but um thank you for being a subscriber
and uh thank you for for listening as
well
appreciate your support this is from
Laura says hello Matt supreme leader of
the world I come to you to have my
husband's bacon judged he says that
today it is perfect
but you as the all-knowing will be able
to tell me if it is or not I have
attached a picture for you
okay Laura perfect bacon you say
um
well
Pride cometh before the fall
but let's see here let's take a look at
it this is the uh let's take let's put
the picture up on the screen this is the
supposedly perfect bacon there it is
okay
so I think I get it now your husband
meant that this is the perfect example
of terrible bacon I think that's what he
meant to say
I'm going to assume that's what he meant
to say
because that would make sense in that
context yeah okay so the coloring is
okay
the actual cook on the bacon is okay
I'm not liking the color at the the top
left corner there you see that bacon uh
that piece is much darker than the rest
so the incongruity the lack of symmetry
there is very troubling to me that at
the very bottom you've got that
horizontal piece that looks sickly and
looks like it has yellow fever or
something
um
so that's a problem but uh all of that
you know would only knock this bacon
down to about a c plus
so if I'm just going based on the cook
and the color I'm going to say c plus
not bad also not great
the thing that drops it the rest of the
way
to an f and becomes grounds for
deportation is the most obvious thing of
all is the mangled Twisted contorted
shape of the bacon itself
so what was your husband doing was he
torturing the bacon to get it to talk I
mean it's already dead someone let them
know there's no it doesn't have anything
to tell them
what did the bacon do to him
that made him feel like he had to draw
and quarter it
yeah when someone puts bacon down in
front of me
I expect to see strips of bacon strips
of bacon not mangled clumps of bacon a
perfectly shaved strip
neatly sitting there
politely waiting for me to eat it
okay I want to see bacon that is proud
um I don't want to see bacon that's
begging me to put it out of its misery
that's my problem
now I uh I assume that when you saw this
bacon by your husband your immediate
response was to contact a divorce a
divorce attorney
and I don't blame you for that
and I'm not saying that it would be
wrong to divorce your husband for making
bacon like this
um I mean certainly legally ethically
biblically you you would be well within
your rights but look you got to think
about the kids Laura if you have kids if
you don't then then get out of there as
fast you can if you do
um you don't want to leave them with a
man who prepares breakfast this way
and so I'm you know I'm I'm sorry that
you're going through this in your
marriage
um I and I another thing is I don't
blame your husband I blame whoever
taught him how to make bacon
that monstrous person
and now I fear that he's going to pass
that down to his own children
and it's like a curse that will never
end
let's put a stop to it